hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar does presumptive drug screening
make sense
toxology practice findings i'm susie
valdez of labyrinth and i will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by waters corporation
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as many questions as
you would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
and this webinar is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
on the bottom of your screen to obtain
those credits i'd now like to welcome
our speaker dr thomas rasano a
toxologist and director at the national
taxology center and professor emeritus
at the albany medical college dr rice
arnold welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
pleasure to participate in this uh
webinar series and to really have that
opportunity uh to share with you our
experience in drug screening practices
both in clinical as well as in forensic
toxicology
i'd like to focus this session
on uh the
question that is uh um
the topic that we have in the as the
title for this session as presumptive
does presumptive growth screening makes
sense and really talk about the the
practice related
uh findings that
we and others have regarding uh the use
of presumptive testing in the current
environment of drug use
and the need for drug detection in that
initial process
uh the experience that i'm going to
share with you comes from two centers as
kyle said the
um experience at the albany medical
center hospital in college comes
primarily from
use of
of screening techniques for both
clinical toxicology especially emergency
medicine toxicology as well as for
medical examiner services that
were provided over a approximate uh
20-year period
in the
22-county region surrounding the albany
medical center
i also would like to share with you
experience that we've had i've had more
recently as a
toxicologist and director of the
national toxicology center which is
shown
below which is just across the street
from
the medical center and in this uh
environment we are heavily focused on uh
not only uh court related testing but
also clinical testing for addiction
medicine and pain management services so
that's the basis of
the
information that i will uh provide but
i'd like to start
by looking at and thinking about the uh
some fundamental principles and methods
uh in our practice of toxicology
and uh screening and confirmation are an
integral part of our analytical
toxicology and form the foundation for
our findings and identifications and
they follow a
principle of sensitive screening
meaning that the methods used for our
screening process optimize drug and
metabolite identification
so
not to miss agents of significance in
that initial screening process
and
confirmation is focused on really the
elimination of false positive screens
and at the same time to
use a an additional
aliquot of a primary specimen to ensure
identity and
lack of
elimination of any potential clerical or
other errors
in the processing of those particular
samples
uh that's that's the principle and it
remains an important principle don't
miss any drugs and don't report any
drugs that uh are not uh true positives
the methods that we use to achieve this
these
principles
of analytical toxicology and our
practice of both forensic and clinical
are the use of uh either presumptive or
definitive methods
and by definition the presumptive method
is a method that identifies the possible
presence
of of a
particular
drug metabolite or their toxin
and it may not be uh definitive in terms
of that particular identification uh but
it uh is an identification of a possible
uh drug or drug class uh most
characteristically used in this
presumptive testing is immunoassay in
this day but certainly we've used
other techniques and including
chromatographic techniques that are not
of the same
resolution or
ability for um co-identification
of diastereo isomers or otherwise it may
not fit into a definitive um testing
methodology definition
on the other hand is the
are the definitive methods that are
specific identifications of
individual drugs or metabolites and uh
the definition has gotten fairly uh
detailed in terms of being with or
without matrix normalization and it
could be qualitative or quantitative and
heavily in the past it was gcms but uh
in recent times much more
liquid chromatography
with ms
and tandem ms
again uh most
recently
the protocols that are used
in the application of these methods are
also
the current protocol is a long-standing
protocol of screen for drug classes by
presumptive methods
and confirm only positives by definitive
methods and that has been used for a
very long time and it's based on the
premise that our presumptive methods are
identifying
potential drugs or drug classes
and the confirmation methods
confirm that presence and give us a
specific identity for the drugs within a
particular class
i would propose that there really are
alternative protocols that are out there
and provide this alternative protocol
which is selectively screened for drugs
and metabolites by defensive method
initially
and confirm and this is again another
variant of it confirm all positives and
negatives
and i'll give you some examples of that
but there are practice changes that are
going on advancing advances in practice
that are occurring that are associated
with not only the methodologies we use
but also the protocols and their
application
the next slide i'd like to show you
what has been going on at least in our
own laboratory for post-mortem
toxicology for many years which is
really the protocol that i gave as an
alternative protocol
which is the uh
screening by definitive uh lc ms ms
methods uh
for the last um
10 or 12 years and before that by gcms
methods
and confirmation then
by uh definitive ms methodology uh
um
as a
as a as a further confirmation of those
findings
what i put up here is a very uh
hard to read slide but it really tries
to uh gather the drug findings and the
frequency of drug findings
for
uh over 10 000 medical examiner cases
that have gone through
the postmortem lab
while i was serving as director of that
laboratory
over about an eight
eight or nine year period
and if they highlight the drugs that are
not following the protocol the new
protocol or the protocol i just
described in terms of definitive
screening there are very few they are
grayed out
uh where we were still using for thc
immuno
casting lithium uh some immunoassays
that were used uh for selective purposes
but in the main that entire uh body of
work uh for determining cause and manner
of death was following that particular
procedure so i'm very familiar with that
procedure i believe it has a great
benefit
but it is not the procedure that is used
across the practice of toxicology
in the various sub-specialty areas of
toxicology
in postmortem as i just described it is
heavily used with a definitive screening
using lod thresholds but the screening
method is used in other areas in
addiction medicine and pain management
there has been a movement
towards initial definitive testing and
oftentimes adapting
confirmatory methods and using a lower
limits of quantitation or limited
detection
for that identification with reporting
of quantitative results for those uh
that casework
court ordered testing uh in our
experience uh in
drug courts
probation departments
child custody cases
often has the use of presumptive
screening
with administrative thresholds followed
by confirmatory testing again for
positive test results
in employment drug testing
written into the initial and continuing
through the
federal workplace program in the u.s is
the use of presumptive screening
with administrative thresholds
well-defined uh for that in fact it's
those thresholds that really dictate the
thresholds that are often used uh in the
commercial production of amino acid
chips and
reagents and procedures
there is the availability now the
authorization now for uh use of
definitive screening and that uh
that approach but it really has been
heavily presumpted and finally emergency
and medicine um
and in clinical toxicology are probably
the most challenging areas to uh make a
change in practice and prejudice
screening uh is used in those areas uh
quite honestly toxidromes are used in
the
emergency department and otherwise to
identify the possibility of stimulants
or other agents and are treated based
upon
about symptomatology and toxidrome
classifications
of the laboratory helps to some extent
but that's the uh because of turnaround
time and the availability of the
definitive testing which is very
challenging to provide in this
environment
so i'd like to show you something from a
number of years ago
where although we were not providing
definitive testing for our emergency
department on a routine basis
we did evaluate the use of definitive
methods and a comparison of those
methods with the
presumptive methods that were used
this is a pilot evaluation of definitive
drug screening in the emergency
department setting
it's 200 ed emergency cases uh they were
consecutive uh urine samples that were
uh sent for uh drug testing and at that
time there uh there was a five panel
amino acid that was uh was performed
and we uh
de-identified those uh and were able to
evaluate those and analyze those by a
uplc msms method
that
was called 64 drugs and metabolites
and what's shown here again hard to show
but uh in terms of the number of agents
but there were four 343 drug findings
gabapentin was the most frequent drug
finding the second most frequent drug
finding was cocaine
metabolite followed by a morphine
level and again across the board
many
benzodiazepines
stimulants and
opiate opioid agents are in this
particular listing
when we looked at and compared that with
the
the findings that were obtained by
present
uh we found that
169 of the 343 drugs were missed by
amino assay and i think this is a very
important point this this slide shows
the false negative rate
for each of the agents
but i think it pointed out something
that we don't
necessarily have as much data as we have
for false positives but the issue of
false negatives and not finding agents
that are there when we looked at this
data
we initially thought there was two
reasons potentially for that
one is the
thresholds used as cutoffs in the amino
acid and secondly is the limited scope
of the amino acids compared to the
number of agents that are out there and
the uh the fact that these assays are
not looking at the
methylphenidates
ketamines mitrogynin you have a pentin
or even fentanyl at that time
which was present in this in this
population at a reasonable frequency
so
this
uh set of data and have stimulated us to
develop uh rather than adapt
methods of confirmation which are really
geared towards confirming classes to
develop a multi-drug quantum
identification as an initial test for
screening and the results of that work
over time is summarized in this slide
it represents a number of advances that
need to be made in terms of us adapting
definitive methods for routine testing
but it includes automation
it includes use of simple
uh dilute and shoot process this is for
urine
drug monitoring
it involves the use of rapid
chromatographic separation and analysis
uh
with very rapid acquisition and the
electronics that are currently available
in uh state-of-the-art mass spectrometry
and it also included um a need for
matrix
uh normalization and i'll speak about
this more in this session and possibly
in in future sessions uh in terms of the
significance of this
but we adapted a new uh technique
that uh in addition in as an alternative
to stable isotope called threshold
accurate calibration somewhat like
standard edition single point standard
edition but it is not a single point
standard edition
it also included hydrolysis so before we
actually look at what we find when we
use this because this is used
very routinely at the national
toxicology center hundreds and hundreds
of samples are analyzed by this
technique and as i said before the the
practice at ntc has then converted from
presumptive
screening to definitive screening using
this particular approach i'd like to
cover two things before we really get
into that data first is the hydrolysis
now that we're actually doing this kind
of numbers of the the number of samples
that we're doing and the amount of
analysis we have plenty of data and in
this particular case i summarized the
data with and without glucuronide
hydrolysis for
almost a thousand drug and metabolite
measurements
and looked at the
um the means and the dispersion around
the mean for the actual percentage of
the drug that we're identifying
with hydrolysis
and you can see that uh
certain drugs exist in the urine sample
in the free state almost exclusively
and that a significant number of the
analytes drugs and metabolites exist as
uh as uh
close to a hundred percent uh group
you're on a date
and that the ability to measure
glucuronidated is is needed uh needs a
hydrolysis step and therefore we find it
very valuable
it also has a implicate and implication
for immunoassay
we in an amino acid for example for
buprenorphine where the actual
levels and and the content of
buprenorphine in the urine is uh almost
100 percent glucometer for buprenorphine
into a large percent for your
buprenorphine
and
unless you have cross-reactivity and
immunoassay with those then they would
will not be a very sensitive measurement
and in fact
you can see that cross-reactivity
evaluated for buprenorphine because it's
so
uh
prominent that uh it is the group
uranium you're measuring but for many of
the other amino acids for
benzodiazepines
whereas you can see uh uh alpha hydroxy
alprazolam
uh
uh cloneazepam of seven aminoclineazepam
those ones that we're having trouble uh
detecting sometimes in our screening
processes using presumptive are highly
highly glucuronidated and it will depend
upon that how that assay interacts if
you look uh sometimes it's hard to find
what the cross reactivity is for those
gluteus so i'll just comment on that
that it's an important part of the assay
system
the second is the important aspect is
the accuracy associated with
with matrix normalization
and uh i won't go into all the details
of it but it is significant there is a
significant
variation in the iron areas associated
with adding the same amount of a drug to
multiple different specimens and there
needs to be this normalization to have
an accurate assessment of either
threshold or a quantitative assessment
we've been for years using stable
isotope for that particular approach
in our quantitative confirmatory methods
this is a practical approach to actually
doing a matrix normalization using the
analyte itself
as a reference material producing a
ratio between
the analyte that's endogenous in the
sample and a consistent amount of
analyte that is is added to every sample
and you can do this in
multi-analyte assays by having
essentially a hundred different uh
reference materials added and spiked
into that particular sample
you can also
once you get a response between the meat
the endogenous
and the spike which is a subtraction of
the need from the spike
you can actually get a response curve
that's very much like uh the ratio to an
internal standard that's used in in
stable isotope uh dilution studies and
to the right shows the quantitation so
it is a different approach that we've
taken but it has been very effective for
us in terms of uh
being able to apply descended methods
for screening
i'll give you one slide that would say
give you a little bit of the uh the
publications associated with this
initially reporting the matrix
normalization technique uh
in 2016 or so and then a quantitative
validation
of the method
at that time i think it was 64 drugs uh
the initial technique was put out with
30 uh some drugs
and uh and as measurements and then a
publication or recently on comparing it
directly to stable isotope for
quantitation
and then a
publication addressing how to confirm
when you are doing this kind of high
volume definitive testing what do we use
for our confirmation methods and the
forensically defensible confirmation so
there's a fair amount of literature they
have out there
associated with the use of this
technique but let's go and take a look
at how this type of panel of testing
over on the left by definitive methods
for specific drugs and metabolites
compares to
a
11 panel
immunoassay on the right hand side
which
allows us to give that direct comparison
i want to show you first a set of data
from 217 addiction medicine cases or
urine samples that were obtained from
from casework
again in a de-identified
state and those particular samples were
tested by the definitive method that i
just described
before
there were 507 positives in those
findings and 1880
i think the negatives and the positives
are
you know equally uh valuable in terms of
being accurate with this is a look at
the
negative rate and the positive rate
for the panel it and it only includes
the analytes that we are part of that 11
panel immunoassay it is not the uh all
of the analytes or the antipsychotics
and other agents that we measure it's
only for the amphetamines benzos
buprenorphine cocaine etc
it also shows you the prevalence this is
a confirmation population so it has a
fairly high prevalence of
drugs in it
and
to give you some sense for validation of
this this is an evaluation of that
definitive method that i just described
to you versus a stable isotope method
and this is for positive negative
identification
and this shows that in this particular
group of samples there were 164
positives by the tac method
of threshold accurate calibration with
that spiking with the reference uh
material standard materials
and there were 303
417 negatives there was complete
concordance
between a
stable isotope method that used analyte
matched deuterated uh or
uh or other to the stan
or c14 standards um as a uh technique so
it compares very well and we have a
great deal of confidence in the
certainty associated with those
particular findings
let's come back to that
group of 217
samples from addiction medicine and take
a look now and over to the left is what
i showed you before was the definitive
udm
results showing
negative definitive negatives definitive
positives and the prevalence now i add
to it the performance of the immunoassay
and first indicate the true true
negatives and true positives again
versus the definitive method itself as
the standard uh
for that particular determination of
true and false
and also then show you the
false negative rate
and the false positive rate and i'd say
that it's very difficult to actually
have this data sometime where you're
actually looking at for immunoassay the
both the false negative and the false
positive
rates but there were 60 false negatives
and 96 false positives and if you take a
look first at the false negatives they
were high for
benzodiazepines
for cocaine
and for opiates
and for and i'll stay
with that there was also false negatives
in some of the other assays at lower
frequencies but still appreciable false
negatives so the actual number of false
negatives is shown here but uh
very high rates uh 15 of the cases were
missed uh for the
cocaine assessment in those cases
benzodiazepines 24 cases of
benzodiazepine positive cases by
definitive method or negative by the
amino acid method and again coming back
to why i'll give you some more
a look at that in a little bit
in terms of either cut offs
in this case since we're really focusing
our definitive methods on the analytes
of interest in those classes of drugs
that are measured by amino acid this is
uh highly uh
a high prevalence of negatives due to
threshold itself and i'll show you that
uh that data in a bit also
false positives we've known of known and
we want to avert the reporting of them
that's why we do confirmations but this
this particular asset had a very high uh
incidence of false positives for
amphetamines we were unable in many of
the cases to find the syntal
that may be our phenological mean that
was the cross-reactant but clearly there
were false positives uh not associated
with amphetamine methamphetamine
or the designer
amphetamines that we had on on the panel
itself either codon assay you also
perform poorly and i'll show you later
why uh in methadone also uh so let's
let's let's do something that is
probably more uh
i'll hold just a moment i have one other
point to make about this so i told you
everything about the definitive testing
for the panel of uh assays that are done
by amino acid and by
immunoassay now i'd like to just show
you that in addition to those false
negatives and false positives there were
also
um
positives by definitive tests that were
not tested by immunoassay including ios
naloxone you have a pentane pregabalin
ephedrines
dexamethorapin
etc so we had additional agents uh not
due to the detection sensitivity because
these assays amino acids were not geared
towards identification but to show you
what's in that population of addiction
medicine uh casework
okay let's let's
let's actually look at cases because
that's what uh you know really gives us
our our best education as peace-oriented
education and i'm going to give you a
just as we almost look at it with a a
case that we have we receive the
medication information in the case uh we
do the definitive testing and we're
provided with the information on the
initial screening that was done by amino
asset so i'll go in a little different
order in this particular case uh this is
a cocaine that was missed by immunoassay
a false negative presumptive screen
that's how it's entitled
treatment with morphine ms cotton a
treatment with zoloft sertraline
a determination by immunoassay of a
positive for opiates a confirmation
performed and findings from working
hydromorphone
when done by the definitive screening
we found we did find morphine at 637
nanograms ml hydromorphone at 79. that's
consistent with a metabolism of warping
to hydromorphone and consistent with
morphine use not the laundry necessarily
divided use so that gives us some good
information we should have that same
information here on the confirmation
methodology but in addition we found
searchline nor norcirculine consistent
with zoloft therapy
and more importantly we found
ventilation
benzoligonine and cocaine
uh which were missed by immunoassay
they're well below the 150 threshold and
cocaine was also found in this
particular case the way we reported is
inconsistent findings of cocaine and
detection
cocaine detection and metabolism
morphine and its metabolite
hydromarphone are consistent with the
prescribed medications as is searcher
lane and research elaine uh medication
consistency with medications so that
comment is put onto the report along
with those findings that's the initial
testing this is a
uh we believe a heroin use case that was
missed by amino acid it is someone who's
on supplicate so they're receiving
buprenorphine without naloxone it's
called supplicated
as a preparation amino acid was positive
for buprenorphine uh it was also
positive for fentanyl however and it was
confirmed positive for fentanyl so there
was a fentanyl finding by immunoassay
but take a look at what you see on a
definitive side buprenorphine is present
uh norburn arcane which does not react
this glucuronide does not react in the
immunoassay but it was very high levels
and in fact nor buprenorphine is usually
our prominent finding
uh fentanyl was uh was found it was
inconsistent with our fentanyl and we
also found beta hydroxy fentanyl we had
a recent publication showing that this
is a metabolite of fentanyl so we now
have it on the panel
and we also found morphine and six
acetyl morphine which were not
identified by amino acid the opiate
assay was negative but take a look at
the concentration go below the 300
nanogram per ml cut off for opiates so i
can see why and also below the 10
nanogram rail cut off for six acetyl
morphing so this was a case of co-use of
fentanyl and in heroin or heroin
together the the current heroin
preparations we see many of these
combinations um but it added the fact
that this was not just a fentanyl but a
fentanyl
heroin
source case
next case is kind of an interesting mess
this is a case of uh use of
alphaslam cloneazepam which was missed
by immunoassay
the prescription was information was
valiant
the findings on immunoassay were
benzodiazepine positive it was actually
not brought to confirmation it was
brought later to confirmation but when
it was confirmed it did find oxazepam
temazepam and nordiazepam this is the
triad that is always seen in our
diazepam cases we very seldom see
diazepam itself although we have it on
the panel but in addition there was
alprazolam
uh alpha hydroxyupazolam and seven
aminoplanazepam
these were inconsistent with the
medications and we reported inconsistent
findings for them along with the
consistent findings for diazepam so we
miss the fact that this individual is
using multiple benzodiazepines in
addition to their
use of diazepam
next case is a case of the limited scope
of
of presumptive screening an adderall
case it was positive for amphetamine
positive
but in addition when we did definitive
as the initial approach we found
methylphenidate and ritalinic acid so we
know that the individual was on ritalin
also methylphenidate and we also found
gammapentan all inconsistent so we found
a significant inconsistent use of drugs
by this individual and in this case by
amino acid we just
just confirmed the use of adderall
itself
this is a false posit now on the false
positive side this is a methadone false
positive we've seen a fair number of
them
and we see them often when the patient
is on circle or quotient therapy because
the quotient metabolites cross react in
the methadone assay which is a reported
finding and by amino acid
they were only treated they were treated
with uh supplicate
which is buprenorphine without naloxone
and also with cereal they found
buprenorphine in that case but they also
found methadone which was an
inconsistency it didn't confirm and uh
we believe that's due to the cortisopine
that we did find when we actually did
definitive testing
and just two more uh quickly that
hydrocodone asset that we see so many
positives hydrocodone is reacting with
oxycodone metabolites and that's the
problem with this assay every time we
have an oxycodone case this is somebody
on oxycontin we get a positive oxycodone
amino acid and a positive hydrocodone
assay and it confirms negative for
hydrocodone this is because these
metabolites are also reacting in the
hydrocodone acid cross-reacting and they
have very high levels the nor oxycodone
highest
metabolite
is beyond our our current calibration
range
and finally
false positive for oxycodone uh and this
is this uh this is a one that i've
actually had court cases uh associated
with this is someone who's on suboxone
therapy now suboxone is a buprenorphine
preparation that has naloxone in it and
when we when we did the testing by when
the testing is done by amino acids they
got a buprenorphine positive but they
also got an oxycodone positive and the
provider was told it was an
inconsistency potentially with oxycodone
if you look at this buprenorphine or
buprenorphine were there and so was
naloxone and so was nor oxymorphone
and this is to us a consistent finding
that we have is that when you metabolize
either
uh nor oxymorphone
or naloxone or naltrexone
you the
de-alkylation that occurs results in the
same end product
now you can call it uh
noroxymorphone
but it's also nor naloxone or nor
naltrexone so we see these patterns of
seeing
naloxone with just this metabolite and
none of the other oxycodone metabolites
and again it's a false positive and
people are sometimes accused of of
oxycodone use when it's really part of
their suboxone medication
so i apologize for the number of cases
but that's what we live with all the
time and that's what we think is the
benefit of it i'm going to just uh
provide you with uh some more
a a study that looked at the clinical
value of definitive testing uh before i
summarize and this is a study that has
been completed and submitted
for publication and is in the review
process heavily uh into the final stage
of the review process
for publication but it's an assessment
of the effectiveness of
them in detection monitoring of drug use
misuse and prescription adherence and i
think that's where we're moving to now
not just a positive finding for a drug
or a judge class but an interpretive
finding relative to drug use to drug
misuse
and to drugs that should be
in the system and are prescribed but are
not there and the study protocol include
95 drug panel
that we i showed you earlier that we had
developed and done in 5 000 cases
and
let's just look at the summary of the
findings
this is the frequency of positive drug
findings when you use this kind of an
expanded panel as the initial test
where we don't wear that
had we used immunoassay that would be
the gauntlet to say we only look at
those agents this is an expanded look at
drugs and expanded look at the drugs
that are in our on the streets in our
populations today there was 28 000
positive drug drug findings in this case
and if you look and i apologize again
it's very hard to represent this number
of drugs and to provide this data in a
form but we we put it in terms of
frequency uh the most frequent being
nicotine metabolite
but the next most frequent being
buprenorphine used heavily in addiction
treatment and also in pain management
and other
opiates opioids and other agents that
are there but if you just look at the
hatched
lines those are all of the
determinations or tests that are
performed for drug or metabolite that
are not included in the 11 panels that i
showed you before so we're really
missing a very significant
uh
findings in terms of drugs that are not
being
monitored for by immuno asset
it also tells you that you need to
actually do more interpretation in the
laboratory there was a recent report a
women's and brigands and women's
hospital showing that if you just send
out these kinds of results to clinicians
you're going to get misinterpretations
because they need to know all the
aspects of metabolism and the nuances of
what we do in the laboratory and it
really begs the question of the
laboratory providing interpretive
reports which give drug use
and also interpret that in relationship
to the medications that are present and
that's what we do very routinely so out
of those 24 000 or so
tests there are 18 000 drug use findings
and now that we know drug use findings
we can look for
relationship with the
current
prescribed medication and report
drugs that are inconsistent positive
findings drugs shouldn't have been there
now obviously the illicits are always
inconsistent positive things but even in
the therapeutics the the oxycodones that
uh over 100 oxy codons that were
reported in this population a subgroup
of all the oxycodones that were
inconsistent and reported as
inconsistent
we know the medications so we know the
frequency of medications in this
population and i'll just make one side
point there are lots of
pain management
and addiction treatment agents but
there's also a fair amount of
psychiatric drug medications
antidepressants antipsychotics and i'll
come back to that point in a moment
this is not adherence this is another
area that we as laboratories can assist
in terms of of an understanding and uh
showing uh that drugs that are not found
no evidence no laboratory evidence of
use of a drug that is being prescribed
and
it's an area that if you look at it
closely heavily into the anti uh the
psychiatric agents quetiapine is first
on the list
of this where we cannot find quatio pain
and we have a sensitive assay with that
hydrolysis that i showed you before and
we have very high levels in the use of
treatment so we really have
information that may you know assist in
not only the care of the patient on the
addiction side but the care of the
patient uh in site service at the same
time
and the final bit of information that
comes out of this uh which is important
information is now that we've
quantitated and we know out of those 5
000 cases the positives we can look at
how
sensitive our detection is
as we move from the thresholds used in
immunoassay down to the thresholds used
in the definitive testing and when you
do that you can see that the detection
rates that this for example is alpra use
of alpha is lamb and alpha hydroxyl
plasma the red is the uh the parent drug
the metabolites in blue it tells you
first of all that the metabolite is a
more sensitive indicator we are grading
positives sooner with the metabolite
higher levels more in the urine than the
parent drug but both of them show you
the increased detection rate associated
with lowering and lowering the threshold
from the thresholds used in immunoassay
down to the threshold used in definitive
testing same is true of fentanyl and
again north fentanyl being a more
sensitive indicator the same is true of
ritalinic acid uh
and it's a tabloid especially
the metabolic vinelonic acid and ritalin
therapy and and uh this pattern was seen
across the uh the board and it allowed
us to have real data to say that as we
move to lower thresholds we are
identifying drugs that are missed
and that is the one of the reasons for
the false negatives that are occurring
and hidden false negatives in
immunoassay testing
these are the comparative cutoffs that
are used for amphetamines we're at 50
and for amino acid 500 for cocaine we're
at 50 versus 150 and that makes a
difference uh
almost half the cases are between these
particular uh levels and morphine we're
at 50 versus
300 and that's the lower limit
for that particular evaluation in that
study
and you can now go and actually predict
the
false negative raising amino acid based
upon this population
where we know the concentration of the
agent and we can say would we have found
it by immunoassay and this mirrors very
closely for example for cocaine a 33
a prediction of a false negative and we
have clear evidence in the
smaller cohort study than earlier that
affirms this uh high level of
false negative for cases
so i'd like to
kind of summarize and really come back
to the question of whether
presumptive methods are meeting our
needs and toxicology
and start with the
some of the findings the drug class in
the united states are not selective and
require additional confirmation testing
to identify specific drug use
well no
false positive rates of up to 100
percent
occur in amino acid and that example was
phencyclidine
we we have some encyclopedia in positive
cases but in the main when uh you know
assay finds sense like routine it is a
false positive uh case but we do have
high rates of false causes in other
assays as i showed you earlier
false negative rates up to 45 percent
also occurring
you know what i say
and the united states therefore does not
meet the basic principle of of drug
screening and toxicology we need
sensitive methods that are detecting the
uh the agents that are in the population
so that we can inform those and then go
on to any specific measurements that are
needed after and this is where i think
we're falling short now in terms of the
fault the false negative rate for this
the false negatives caused by high
cutoffs and by limited scope of testing
the study also shows and the experience
over time also shows that definitive
screening application is uh is
demonstrable and usable in routine
practice and shows improved screening
sensitivity selectivity and clinical
effectiveness so in conclusion i would
say practice based evidence shows that
presumptive presumptive
screening does not make sense
uh and that we really need to
look towards advances in practice that
will allow us to use uh our more
sensitive and specific measurements in
the initial testing process and that is
quite a challenge because uh i think the
first response is how would we ever you
know
convert to definitive testing across all
of our practices and i think it is going
to take innovation in terms of
automation
techniques for matrix normalization
and
data management and
i hope it's some future session to be
able to uh
give you some more information on some
of those challenges and
speak more specifically about data
association with them but at this point
i would like to say it's again a
pleasure participating in this and i i
look forward to
answering any questions that you may
have and also learning uh from those who
are out there in practice because it
really is a
collaborative process uh and
uh to for us to continue to advance the
practice of toxicology so thank you
and thank you dr rosano for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
so it looks like dr rosano we already
have some great questions coming in from
our audience members
our first question
is
how um time element presumptive amino
acid using drug test kits is the fastest
available screening method what is the
time element involved in uplc msms for a
single urine sample
so we uh do most of our uh testing in a
batch format
and samples are processed uh
sample prep takes
place in the morning analysis by late
morning
and the actual testing in terms of the
chromatographic testing
takes into the evening and into the
night so it is the next day
next morning a results review and
for the uh initial testing
if that's in a forensic environment
then there would be the findings from
that and it would be on the next run of
the next day that particular next day
that would be put on for the
confirmation so for the initial
screening it is uh next day
for confirmation it is the uh it is a
two-day uh process for that
thank you so
much costing of alternative versus
current protocol could you talk a little
bit more about that
i'm sorry the cost of it is
the question
the question costing of alternative
versus
current protocol what could you talk a
little bit about maybe costing of
alternatives
the uh the the cost is really uh there
are two aspects of the cost that we we
have seen one is the the the investment
that needs to be made in capital
investment and equipment and personnel
uh for the definitive testing uh which
is higher than the than the
capital investment for immunoassay
screening or presumptive testing on the
other hand we also looked at the
variable cost in terms of the ongoing
cost
which in amino assay is is the the
individual reagents for each analysis
and in mass spec uh there is there is
lesser amounts of of that variable cost
so it really is a volume issue uh and it
also is an industry uh issue in terms of
the cost of capital otherwise but as you
get to higher volumes
um and we find it about
between 12 and 15 000 cases per year
that if you take a look at the analysis
between the two that they are
very uh similar in cost in that with
high volume uh the cost immunoassay
actually is higher because of the the
ongoing uh reagent cost for each of
those tests so at the lower volumes
amino acid really is a more cost
effective um but
at higher volumes and above it really uh
it inverts
in terms of
the cost
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in
our next question from an audience
member how did you select the drug panel
for your definitive panel
well that's that's a
question that we we addressed very early
on in terms of how do we transition
to
uh definitive screening uh from
presumptive and we initially developed
panels that actually uh were the
individual drugs that are in the classes
of drugs
uh performed by immunoassay so we had a
very what would be called a very basic
panel uh that would be uh inclusive of
all of the testing that was currently
done in the classes of drugs by you know
assay and did have that available but
very rapidly we moved toward the
expansion of that because as you'll see
as you see in the data there are
drugs in use
that are not being
identified
and tested for by immunoassay so we went
to a panel that was initially a drug
abuse panel that became a approximately
a 64 drug use and and included opiates
opioids benzodiazepines
of stimulants
and other agents
and and continue we continue to evolve
and designer drugs that uh come on
we are looking at closely for addition
to it
so we have that panel but we at a
particular
development point we also started
looking at the therapeutics
and uh and this whole issue of the
antipsychotics and antidepressants uh
were added so now we're at about a about
195 to 100
drugs in a full panel
and
our approach to it is
is that we acquire the data on all drugs
the fundamental ion data on all drugs
but only analyze the
that data for actual drug findings for
the
the drugs that were ordered in the case
so we're able to be very flexible in
terms of doing basic panels
or the drug of abuse panels or the drug
of abuse plus the therapeutics
in a single chromatographic process
and it is going to take uh efficiencies
to make the the use of
this very um
effective uh definitive procedure
applicable in various settings and
we have a i hope to have a
session coming up to actually address
some of these details but that's in
summary of what we've done to uh
identify panels
thank you so much dr rosano we have time
for one more question how does the
initial definitive testing effect turn
around time for results
uh well as i've spoken of earlier the
the uh the initial testing itself is uh
started uh
on day one and is completed on on the
day after and results are uh available
uh in a clinical setting now that we've
gone direct to definitive uh there is
the opportunity uh to report a
definitive results if initial testing
is in a report as i said in the forensic
uh
we will never get away from the need to
have a second test even though we have
enough
certainty
associated with the identification in
the initial test
we will we will still need the second
test so the those samples that are
positive and uh in forensic uh case
where they are then evaluated by the
certifying scientist and and put on that
the run of the next day for the
following uh for that particular
preparation and then a re-analysis from
a primary uh
specimen so it is it is uh is uh
approximate uh a two-day uh
process of of of testing for full
forensic um
casework uh and oh
hey and again we're doing the initial
testing in a definitive mode so
negatives are done by definitive since
we are using large panels for the
confirmation testing uh which we have
reported the use of top for example in
confirmation testing we are able to
actually re-analyze the even the
positives and the negatives in those
particular cases for confirmation of
positives and and negatives
in terms of our findings
dr rosano thank you for your
presentation today cern for your
important research would you like to
provide any final comments for our
audience before we go
yes i think that this is is a challenge
and all of us uh this has been a
significant number of years of
development at our own laboratory
i think that it's a challenge for the
industry
cells to actually uh provide us with the
kind of automation
that is needed provide us with the
informatic support uh we didn't have a
chance to really talk about it but the
amount of data that one generates in the
system requires an informatics solution
that allows the uh the
the analyst and the certifiers to
actually look at the the important data
and not uh have to do a lot of
calculation of information so we have
many things that are challenging to us
in our laboratories in the industry but
fundamentally in terms of what's going
on in terms of drug use and misuse
and uh
and compliance issues we really have a
need
to address this and to
meet this challenge
thank you sir again for your
presentation and i would like to also
thank lab roots and our sponsor waters
corporation for underwriting today's
educational webcast and thank you again
dr rosano before we go i also want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast will be viewed on
demand laborats will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone stay safe goodbye
a pleasure thank you